[Musique]
c'est une musique qu'on a peu l'habitude
d'entendre dans ce parc du 19e
arrondissement de la capitale
[Musique]
ces jeunes en jeans baggy ne sont pas
des skateurs d'opérette mais de vrais
danseurs d'opéra un opéra traditionnel
tibétain
[Musique]
le meneur de balès et tashi lui et ses
amis ont entre 25 et 30 ans et sont en
france depuis quelques mois seulement
ils ont fui leur tibet natale
[Musique]
cette danse qu'il prépare c'est pour le
l'osar le nouvel an tibétain qui
approche à grands pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est occupé par la chine
aux costumes nos danses et notre
identité ce sont les seules choses que
l'on peut montrer au monde c'est
important pour nous
tashi devrait bientôt obtenir le statut
de réfugié politique au tibet il était
artiste ses chansons à la gloire du
dalaï lama le chef spirituel tibétain en
exil n'ont pas été du goût de l'occupant
chinois
trois jours de prison puis la fuite ici
au moins il peut revendiquer sans
entrave un tibet libre
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré un chinois dont parc on a
discuté du tibet et pour lui c'est
évident c'est une région chinoise
j'ai tenté de lui expliquer la situation
il m'a dit mais non c'est faux il a
appris à l'école
qu'est ce que vous voulez je lui dise je
lui en veux pas c'est ce qu'on lui a
enseigné
mais l'histoire est écrite par les
vainqueurs et aujourd'hui sur la carte
du globe le tibet appartient à la chine
la nationalité tibétaine est reconnu par
aucune instance internationale
en 1950 sous l'impulsion de mao les
chinois annexe le pays
neuf ans plus tard le dalaï lama menaces
et trouve refuge en inde il y établit
son gouvernement en exil à dharamsala
dans l'est du pays
sans chef le tibet colonisé sa culture
anéantit ses résistants supprimés
[Musique]
en un demi-siècle l'oppression aurait
fait plus d'un million deux cent mille
morts selon le gouvernement en exil
aujourd'hui au tibet plus d'un habitant
sur deux chinois
plus de cent cinquante mille tibétains
vivent hors du tibet en france ils ne
sont pas plus d'un millier presque tous
présents cet après midi à paris sur le
parvis du trocadéro tashi bien sûr et
dans les rangs c'est sa première manif
en terre démocratique
comme chaque année à la même date on
célèbre la rébellion de 1959
le 10 mars les tibétains de toutes les
provinces sont unis et soulever contre
le gouvernement chinois le 10 mars 1959
nous les tibétains on a réellement perdu
notre pays
au tibet les photos du dalaï lama icône
de la protestation sont interdites ici
on les affiches et on lit ses messages
depuis ce soulèvement écrasé par la
chine en 1959 le chef religieux n'a
cessé de proscrire l'usagé de la
violence
conforme aux principes bouddhiste la
voie choisie par les tibétains et la
protestation pacifique
[Musique]
nous sommes une très petite population
prendre les armes appliquerait
énormément de moyens une très grande
puissance chose que nous n'avons pas
[Musique]
la non violence une méthode qui remporte
l'adhésion de l'opinion internationale
mais les tibétains en exil réclame plus
qu'un soutien moral aux
événements imprévus ou non les gens il
s'est relevé et m
c'était
[Musique]
la manif s'achève devant l'ambassade de
chine
impossible dans l'approché est plus de
200 m les tibétains connaissent bien les
limites de la realpolitik
en 2000 au tibet était un pays libre et
indépendant
une nouvelle génération team aidant à
prendre leurs affaires et gérer les amis
dans
la diaspora tibétaine est l'une des plus
organiser de la planète elle à son
parlement et son gouvernement exilé en
inde à dharamsala
des institutions renouvelé tous les cinq
ans
à paris comme dans les plus grandes
villes du monde les élections c'est pour
aujourd'hui
tenzin loupe et le vice-président de la
communauté tibétaine de paris ce sous
sol d'immeuble à côté du périph c'est le
bureau du tibet en d'autres termes
l'ambassade officieuse du pays
aujourd'hui tenzin fera office
d'assesseurs
qui coachait petit gilet sont gays
gagnent un coach étape terrine de
canard aux attentes
une seule condition pour voter être en
possession de ce livret vert le document
a tout d'un passeport mais il est
officiel que pour les tibétains il n'est
reconnue par aucun pays du globe
pour tous cette élection est un tournant
historique le dalaï lama vient
d'annoncer qu'il renonçait à diriger le
gouvernement en exil leaders religieux
il était aussi le chef politique de la
diaspora désormais il sera uniquement le
chef spirituel des tibétains le dalaï
lama vient d'instaurer la séparation du
temps et de l'état
[Musique]
chaque tibétain doit donc voter pour
l'un des trois candidats au poste de
premier ministre c'est lui maintenant
qui décidera de la voie à suivre pour
négocier l'autonomie du tibet
[Musique]
si l'on choisit quelqu'un de jeune et
dynamique
nous montrerons tous à la chine qu'il y
ait un team est nouveau et moderne
après dépouillement les résultats du
vote partiront pour dharamsala
[Musique]
en exil des tibétains s'organise dans la
vie sociale comme en politique
quartier des abbesses au coeur d'un
paris de carte postale tenzin l'eau
douce qui tient avec sa femme un
restaurant tibétains en cuisine on
embauche que des tibétains fraîchement
arrivé pour la préparation des moments
les raviolis à la sauce himalayenne
le resto de tenzin c'est le camp de base
des nouveaux arrivants moyenne d'âge
moins de 30 ans
d'avenir de la culture tibétaine 7e
en traversant les continents les
tibétains de paris ont aussi traversé
les époques
ce soir selon le calendrier du tibet ces
l'osr traduisait la nouvelle année
adieu 2137 demain nous serons en 2138
l'année du lapin de faire
[Musique]
sur scène on joue l'opéra répéter dans
le parc du 19e arrondissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans une salle des fêtes de banlieue la
petite communauté des tibétains de paris
est au grand complet
tashi l'artiste a retrouvé un public et
renouer avec les chansons qui au tibet
lui ont valu la prison
[Musique]
c'est notre façon de célébrer les grands
événements les chinois savent qu'à
chaque fête au tibet on se retrouve tous
ensemble on chante ensemble on danse
ensemble en bois notre thé de chang
ensemble ces salles tibet c'est ça les
tibétains nos ancêtres vivaient comme ça
[Musique]
mais les ancêtres de thaçi était loin de
se douter que leur enfant hériterait
aussi des classiques de la culture pop
après des années de frustration ce soir
on chante sans modération
2138 l'odyssée des tibétains est loin
d'être terminée
[Musique]